so meanwhile it is important to note
that
politics is indeed ruining everything i
think this is the biggest problem in the
country today
really right now is that politics has
infused every aspect of our life there
is nothing in our lives that is not
political
and something that you saw with gina
carano you can't even watch an
entertainment show now
without having to think about politics
you saw this with sports
this is having a dramatic impact on the
social fabric it's something i've been
talking about for a very long time
it is very very bad for the country and
the left has wanted for a long time ever
since the 60s when the left declared
that the personal is political
meaning that whatever you do in your
personal life is actively a a political
move
right your sex life is political what
you shop for is political where you went
to school
is political what this leads to is
identity groups based on politics
and those identity groups are feel
threatened the moment somebody disagrees
with them
that leads to his hearing a part of the
culture see here's the thing normally
an identity group is rooted in immutable
characteristics
right being black is being in an
identity group at the very least because
if somebody attacks the color of your
skin
that is an attack on an immutable
characteristic shared by millions of
other people
if somebody attacks your politics that
is not an identity group
right politics as an identity group is
mutable you can shift your politics
people do it all the time
so there is a difference between
attacking somebody for race and
attacking someone for politics but the
problem is
once you make politics your identity and
that identity is expressed
in a wide variety of ways across all of
american life what you end up with
is a mathematics whereby where you shop
is political and if i don't shop at your
store this means i'm insulting you and
i'm offending you and i've done
something wrong
to you as a human being reason magazine
has a great piece out today
by j.d cecile titled politics is seeping
into our daily life and ruining
everything he runs down
some of the data on this point according
to a new paper in the journal of public
policy and marketing
by researchers from arizona state
university the university of wyoming and
four other u.s universities
political polarization is having
far-reaching impacts on american life
harming consumer welfare and creating
challenges for people ranging from
elected officials and policymakers to
corporate executives and marketers
the researchers find that people's
chosen political identities become
self-reinforcing
through associations with groups with
shared beliefs our associations can even
create a group shared specific reality
that makes it harder to relate to those
with opposing views
according to the researchers as society
has become increasingly polarized
politicians objectives diverge and their
animosity toward the opposition grows
thereby reducing opportunity for
compromise
partisan incivility is a major reason
for failed dialogue uncivil exchanges
result in disagreement and greater
polarization regardless of the evidence
presented
according to reason people's partisan
identities influence the range of people
with whom they are willing to have
relationships
the brands they purchase and the jobs
they take in an era of public health
concerns people choose positions on
matters like vaccines or mass squaring
not based on rational assessment of the
issues but on a plug-and-play adoption
of their tribes at stances
the researchers say with political
positions influencing decisions
people may sacrifice wages lose out on
jobs make sob up sub-optimal purchases
and disregard opportunities to save for
example research has found that
employees accept lower wages to work for
politically like-minded entities
and people may select higher-priced
products or ones that offer less
functional value
polarization has the potential to
prevent neighbors or colleagues of
opposing parties from developing
friendships
this ultimately deprives individuals of
intellectual diversity among other
things
now this all builds on a mountain of
data there is a 2018 survey that found
that nearly two-thirds of consumers
around the world
will either buy or boycott a brand
solely because of its position on a
social or political issue
in the united states that number was 59
in 2020 there was another survey it
reported
that 83 of millennials find it important
for the companies they buy from
full line with their values which means
that the price
and quality of the products is actually
secondary which is a problem in the
marketplace if you want better things
you need competition in the marketplace
not based on the politics of the
corporation but instead based on the
quality of the product that's how we all
get better products
the reason you get new iphones every
couple years is because
android is on their tail but if you've
decided that you don't like the politics
and android as you're always going to
buy the iphone well that just means that
you're providing a base
for a company that no longer has to
innovate christine morman wrote for
forbes
these leaders hope their political
activism will help shape public opinion
and potentially lead to lasting change
while simultaneously cementing their
reputations as moral leaders or change
agents
since then the trend has only
intensified recent events accelerate a
broader movement in business to address
social and political issues according to
a piece in the wall street journal from
january pennsylvania state university
daniel
professor daniel delaposta asked in a
study published in june 2020
what if polarization is less like a
fence getting taller over time and more
like an oil spill that spreads from its
source to gradually taint more and more
previously apolitical attitudes
opinions and preferences even many
initially apolitical lifestyle
characteristics from musical taste to
belief in astrology
can become politicized as signals for
deeper beliefs and preferences
a tendency most saliently captured in
the popular image of the latte liberal
it also happens to be that when you do
all of this what you do is make american
life worse because there is no common
way that we can share anything
if i share a product with somebody i
have now poisoned the product
this happens regularly by the way
there's a survey that was done fairly
recently
in which from harvard business review i
believe it's 2018
and they created essentially a focus
group
and the focus group was made up of
conservatives and liberals and people in
between
and the focus group examined two
companies
one company well actually three one was
a company it's just called
you know generic corp and generic corp
had no politics
and they asked people what they thought
of generic corp and turns out people
were okay with generic corp it was fine
then generic corp identified as a
liberal organization
and the numbers were exactly the same
people were like okay we're fine with
that that's cool
then generic corp identified in this
study as a conservative organization
and its public perception dropped 33
points
33 points obviously that was all
liberals and leftists
who decided that they hated this
corporation they understand that the
default
is that corporations are liberal this is
the thing about renormalization of
american politics i've talked about this
at length and this is really what reason
is talking about
the renormalization of american politics
happens when one intransigent group of
people
decide that they are not going to go
along with commonly held beliefs
and they cuddle everybody else into
silence they emotionally blackmail
everybody else
the left is the only group in america
right now that feels comfortable
in terms of our public daily life
they're the only group of people who
feel comfortable
polls show this independents do not feel
comfortable republicans do not feel
comfortable
mainstream liberals many don't feel
comfortable they feel like they can't
speak up
and they can't speak out and they can't
just you know go to a ballgame or go to
a restaurant or decide what kind of
product they want without having to fear
that they are going to be judged
and castigated that's a terrible thing
for the country it means that we have
nothing in common anymore
i mean it's been it's been a long time
since we could even pretend that we had
the american flag in common half the
country thinks the american flag stands
for oppression apparently
so what exactly is going to hold us
together as things become more and more
political
things get worse and worse the answer is
not politics the answer is
community connection the answer is
church the answer is getting to know
your neighbors and having conversations
with your neighbors but all of this
has been banned the local authoritarians
don't want you to know your neighbor
in fact if you get to know your neighbor
and your neighbor happens to be a
republican they will cancel you
they will go after you for having the
temerity to have a conversation with
that person
this is the culture that we now occupy
and it's a culture that we're going to
have to fight back against
if we actually wish to preserve the
country moving forward into the future
unfortunately too many people don't want
to preserve the country this way
which is the reason why you are seeing
that big tech is about to be brought in
before house democrats and they're going
to grill top executives
at facebook google and twitter as
democrats take fresh aim at the tech
giant
for failing to crack down on dangerous
political falsehoods and disinformation
the idea here again from house democrats
being that if you allow people to speak
freely in ways we disagree with you're
making the country worse no you know
what makes the country worse
the idea that we don't all get to have
our opinion and then have conversation
about those opinions
lest we grant credence to the evil among
us
that is not treating your fellow
american as a fellow american and
treating your fellow american as an
enemy
and that's the direction in which we are
moving facts don't care about your
feelings and it's a fact that the ben
shapiro show is the largest conservative
podcast in the nation
be sure to hit the subscribe button to
stay up to date on all of our content